У сучасній Росії зараз наявне
певне відчуття незахищеності
У росіянина Ігоря Абизова попереду
ще два роки університету
проте він вже нині розмірковує
про зміну місця проживання
Здавалося б, престижний виш,
Московська вища школа економіки
і перспективна професія:
Ігор вивчає економіку та статистику
Проте у Росії, зізнається він, йому бракує
впевненості у завтрашньому дні
Навіть якщо взяти якийсь звичайнісінький приклад
то я, приміром, дуже сильно боюся поліцейських
Тому що, грубо кажучи, це люди
які в першу чергу повинні тебе захищати
але зараз, коли назустріч йде поліцейський
я передусім думаю: блін,
хоч би він до мене не підійшов
Після закінчення університету Ігор хоче продовжити навчання за кордоном
бажано у Європі
Як облаштоване життя за кордоном, він
як і більшість молодих людей,
знає лише поверхнево
Водночас бажаючих емігрувати серед російської молоді нині значно побільшало
за даними Всеросійського центру вивчення громадської думки, це 31 відсоток
найвищий показник за останні п'ять років
На першому місці в рейтингу країн призначення у нас стоїть Німеччина
На другому місці Сполучені Штати,
на третьому - Іспанія
Однак в цілому, якщо ми поглянемо на список країн
то побачимо, що основна частина з них - країни Європи
в яких дещо кращий клімат, а життя видається
більш комфортним та забезпеченим
Бажання поїхати - це не втеча від російської дійсності, запевняють соціологи
Те ж опитування показало, що з віком
кількість бажаючих покинути батьківщину різко зменшується
Крім того, варто відзначити
що серед потенційних емігрантів тих, хто не в теорії
а на практиці готується до переїзду - меншість
Коли ми запитуємо їх про те
чи вдаються вони до певних кроків, аби здійснити свою мрію про переїзд
з'ясовується, що близько
10 відсотків вивчають мову
близько 10 відсотків збирають інформацію про іншу країну
Тобто зовсім невелика частина людей, які мріють про життя деінде
щось реально для цього роблять
Юлія Вагапова вже отримала вищу освіту, відпрацювала рік на радіо
а зрештою дійшла висновку, що треба змінити місце проживання
Зібрала документи, подала заявку й отримала грант на річне навчання за кордоном
У жовтні - переїзд у Тель-Авів
При цьому Юлія - не з тих,
хто не вірить у майбутнє Росії
Проте своє майбутнє вона
все ж бачить за її межами
Принаймні найближче
А там, каже Юлія, буде видно - повертатися
на батьківщину чи переїхати до США
Ти хочеш розвиватися там, де це цінують
там, де за твою працю платять відповідні гроші
там, де в тебе є певні можливості, свобода висловлювання, свобода слова тощо
Звісно, хочеться спробувати пожити там
де тобі гарантують певну стабільність
Найважче, пояснює Юлія, залишати рідних та друзів
З деякими з них вона пройшла і вогонь, і воду, і мітинги проти корупції
От за мітингами, де жорстко затримували ровесників, зізнається Юлія
вона точно не сумуватиме